[Musique]
c'est moi le train pour garges c'est ce
qu'elle a
[Musique]
dames
garches par des excuses avancées
oui moi je sais rien
[Musique]
les six interceptions
allison les bêtes usa bat bonjour
martine boghossian cadre de santé
techau interne hugo wagner toronto ce
cas tu n'en demandera ce que tu as loupé
on va pas reprendre depuis le début un
deuxième temps sur la gauche c'est le
grand duché de service le docteur simoni
sur votre droite
l'accès des urgences à l'hôpital vous
savez peut-être face à l'ensemble des
familles ont tous les pavillons sont
reliés par beaucoup en vitré comme
celui-ci des questions est ce qu'ils
sont ou les médecins les médecins
titulaires sont joignables par téléphone
donc vous n'hésitez pas à les appeler
presque tu attendue pour mi de 6 à rien
de paniquer je panique pas du tout je
prends deux secteurs vous prenez un
secteur chacun ok moi je peux prendre le
secteur de parce que je les connais bien
enfin je vois la jci et externes ce que
d'habitude je prends les liens étroits
et ont su prendre quatre c'est là
gériatrique tu verras c'est pas
compliqué
plus fort
c'est quoi le problème est qu'il 800 mhz
et un patient camors un méningocoque
bien bel air apparemment tous ceux qui
ont été en contact très chez eux et
prennent un traitement préventif
il ya tous les médecins de nos services
pas mal d'idées eu des aides soignantes
et une ou deux personnes d urgence si
j'ai bien compris il y en a pour 24
heures c'est une maison de médecins pas
toi si tu as besoin tu appelles lantieri
ok c'est le piège du secteur 4 mai les
patients doivent être bien typés ballon
ils savent pas et c'est un honneur mais
s'il me demande où sont les médecins ont
battu leur dit que c'est toi le médecin
attendons mais c'est une pathologie je
peux pas prendre en charge plus comment
s'appelle le 15
je sais que j ai envoyé à
l'administration ton dossier qu'est ce
que tu veux que je te dise il était pour
moi moi tu vas mourir je te dis que je
les plus fort voir avec l'administration
bonjour non mais c'est pas normal c'est
pas comme ça que ça doit se passer la
docteure bacha j'ai beaucoup de travail
là où j'avais service avec trois
internes d'accord oui on est tous
d'abord de regard des procédures
d'accords et ben justement il ya des
procédures et je les ai suivi les
procédures on me demande de revenir sur
mineure quand elle est vraiment occupé
la chambre est rappelé qu'une seconde
saison pleine oui c'est le dr match je
suis désolé il est dit que vous étiez
occupé mais c'est gentil remercier vous
refermez derrière vous sinon plus j'ai
six médecins bloqués chez eux on a
réalisé urgences sont débordées ils
peuvent se détacher personnes je parle
même pas des ide les aides soignantes
depuis ce matin je me bats avec les
plannings pour essayer de basculer et
soignants en médecine interne
j'ai pas beaucoup de temps la rbnz
portera le dossier du patient que mort
de même un gros crac heures je passe en
médecine interne et mehdi piloter chez
toi non mais je n'ai pas ce dossier les
parties et le corps pour le top 6 je
comprends pas c'est pas à moi de le
faire
il n'ya rien à comprendre il ya un
risque de contagion d'accord donc moi je
suis les ordres de la rs point c'est le
protocole ces cochons qui s'occupe des
autopsies dans ces cas là franchement
cochant l'option de ce protocole
c'est qu'ils m'ont dit tu as réalisé les
ffi en poste depuis 2010 mais qu'il faut
que tu t'occupes de ce dossier c'est un
tu vas pas retrouvé de poste voie le
jour même
ici bas n'y a pas de chef et en rien sa
rôle justement il ya ta mère qui ment
voilà pour des tentatives de suicide
elle est tirée d'affaires mais on peux
pas la garder en observation
on n'a pas assez a dit vous pourriez
apprendre ici ouais carrément musée de
la place c'est au medac
elle est un peu bêtement tâter est on
c'est sa sixième tentative
ah quand même justement il faut la
surveiller quoi tu préfère pas en parler
avec tes collègues avant d'apprendre
mais non c'est bon je te dis je gère
s'inquiète simon suter bon allez un peu
plus tard
[Musique]
viens pas nous vers un docteur sigmund
aujourd'hui non il sera l'un d'eux ne
vous inquiétez pas il faut pas lui en
vouloir
le lundi c'est le jour de sat et ça le
rend agressif mais c'est pas toutes les
trois semaines la testostérone mais les
spéciales c'est comme ça à ma mecteau
mais ils me retiraient ses tétons on va
regarder ça vous permettez
le froide c'est propre c'est bien ça
c'est catherine ville je vous fais pas
mal non bon à plus tard merci au revoir
en 201 jenson je vais me saouler g il a
fait une infection rugby landes dans
deux heures sinon tf poèmes tout va bien
ils réclament laurens à mastectomie rs
ça cicatrise
il dit qu'il a toujours des sautes
d'humeur tu as demandé un bilan et un
dock rhino merci heureusement tout y est
il fallait que ça tombe le jour de la
rentrée des internes des deux os et
c'est leur premier stage au go wagner
c'est une trompette le match et allison
à la pas un prénom facile non mais ça va
c'est pour 24 heures est inquiète pas je
gère ton service au revoir je te martin
j'imagine y est plus sympa maintenant
elle est très sympa martin claude tu
veux pas que je lui dise là pour nous
deux c'est ridicule elle va finir par le
savoir
c'est une série qui s'étaient mis
d'accord je viens dans mon service je
termine mon internat mais j'ai pas envie
d'être la femme de samsung
je vais pas qu'on était marié faucher
retour bon ben vas-y mollo on se
rappelle ce soir promis
com
[Musique]
cap a commencé les dossiers c'est bien
mais à un moment j'ai besoin que tu vas
voir les patients une fois les
prescriptions
moi j'ai les passionnés ils examinent et
ausculté bonjour je viens pour la visite
je la trouve l interne que vous ausculté
savait passer une bonne nuit monsieur
monsieur
qu'est-ce qui se passe tu appelles qu'il
a derrière on va appeler la famille
plutôt hockey t'oubliera pas de faire un
certificat de décès
et des journées bonjour j'ai dans le
service de médecine interne
tu vas rester ici quelques jours le
temps que tiger
moi j'suis le docteur wagner mais tu
peux m'appeler ego si tu veux ça c'est
marion c'est ça
elle scellera si ça va pas c'est a
besoin de nous parler tu hésites pas
surtout tiens regarde hop ça tapis
dessus j'en ai la direccte d'accord
moi je repasse au vert tout à l'heure
[Musique]
moi je vais te laisser trop payés
masseret
m
ça va aller ça paye alité chez toi pour
nettoyer maintenant tu prends une
compresse et m'a dit tu attends oui tu
t'inquiètes pas si peu
[Musique]
ans
à
allison très bon il est très très bon
elle est très bien tu veux un homme est
interne à sa place non bon d'accord elle
est nulle mais bon horaire vous êtes au
complet c'est mon arbre je leur demande
avec les médecins reviennent dans 18
heures exactement de série n 18 heures
pour gesture gars n'aiment pas trop nul
le nom ton fils ce n'est pas le problème
écoutons peut rien faire on arrête pas
là c'est pas pour rien qu'on vous a
envoyé le ts une ts ceux ci bat ats
contrairement terne et je te le rend à
minuit non c'est non pas une heure pas
dix minutes tu te démerdes tu as voulu
aller dans le service de ton acte à sion
si vous n'avez pas envie de ça ça vaut
rien enfin bon je l'avais trouvé un
stage devait à onet histoire de finir en
beauté mais tu préfères la médecine
interne
oui mais non si moi je suis là nos six
mois c'est bon on verra si t'as pas
perdu la main
[Musique]
il avait fait des autopsies ce matin
club du voyage tour jamais être
passionnant n'empêche pas ce que tu fais
ouais et est ce que moi je pourrais
passer
zut je regarde pas longtemps tant kwakwa
pédiatrie et honnête
herbert qui peut plier les passionnés
sommes nous devenus ces merdes
faites-moi sa place il y est
tu connais un impact médecine est gage
c'est un franco albanais mais c'est vrai
on vous avait plus que pour la journée
surtout si c'est moi le chef à temps et
du coup tu as fait combien de temps est
aujourd'hui
vous verrez en médecine interne tout le
monde le sait les attendait justement
aujourd'hui en train de passer donc un
peu de respect rabadan
c'est quoi c'est est-ce que tu as
accepté dans le service cette mission ça
se décide pas tout seul on en discute
d'abord à tous de venir ça ne donne pas
tous les droits
je tiens le service à bout de bras tu me
fais ce genre de coup on met en jeu sa
part médecine la aux américains
[Applaudissements]
non mais attends tu dis rien du tout
c'est pas ma chère tu n'as pas d'ordre
et si j'arrive je fais ce que je veux
est d'accord ok cet été est en charge
tout seul c'est ta responsabilité
[Applaudissements]
dray
[Musique]
à
je retourne bosser là
[Musique]
voilà ouais alors alors
alors on est on est on est sur la bonne
voie ça vous fait encore souffrir
oui mais je commence à m'habituer à
china vous refaire un pansement monde et
on continue aux antibiotiques
très bien dis moi qui tu connais un club
en tous cas pièce à éclore en tous cas
la nouvelle interne pas vraiment enfin
celle en réanimation à normande en voilà
même fini major de sa promo je vous fais
pas mal peut cesser c'est très bien ça
cicatrise bien même bon courage
ça y est j'ai fini et la docteure
lentilles qui a tout validé du coup je
me dis lui que j'ai mon erreur à 19
heures c'est un peu tordu je peux rester
jusqu'à 19h tu veux enfin 18h45 non
seulement tu restes jusqu'à 19h mais tu
restes toute la nuit vingt-quatre heures
à tenir c'est pas la mer à boire
on va rester la nuit c'est le principe
en garde martin reste hugo reste je
reste tu restes il ya tout là dedans
tout ça et quand tu auras fini de sa
pause les familles du vieux monsieur et
l'a vu monsieur oui je sais pas vu sur
le médecin qui reparle donc toi fais ton
passion son certificat de décès ta
famille mais tu vas très bientôt sortir
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé je sais pas
je suis arrivé ce matin il était déjà
comme ça j'ai gbe pellard et enfin je
l'aï fait vous savez s'il a eu mal je
sais pas vous vous le connaissez enfin
vous le faisiez je vous ai jamais vu
passer tous les jours je suis dit m
les docteurs entier il est pas là non il
est pas là aujourd'hui
les par contre ce sera là demain il va
vous amener dans la salle des familles
pour signer des papiers et on va te
perds lui on va l'emmener à la morgue
on va
désolé
or dieu
[Musique]
arbel dans le cube su te plaît bonjour
je rencontre monsieur qui est là
c'est de l'autre côté la marque ici
c'est le service dans la pointe et de
médecine légale et c'est vous qui faites
les aussi tu as fait le certificat de ça
et hop je suis pas tout le monde tous à
94 insuffisance cardiaque en phase
terminale donc bat le coeur s'est arrêté
si toi j'aurais pu faire quelque chose
non j'ai pas tué non pas du tout parce
que ward faut être humble un peu la mort
que c'est sur sa droite
journey merci
dr en tous cas il ya un monsieur de
robert qui est là pour sa promotion
je voulais l'installer en 116 ya
personne bonjour vous avez rendez vous
non mais le docteur simoni prend
toujours le sud robert comme ça à la
volée et les 18 heures monsieur lambert
n'a qu'à revenir demain et les chiens
sont pas admis dans les hôpitaux
non mais il va pas attendre demain matin
il est là de cassis me dit toujours que
quand on est impatients qui est là est
ce que ceux qui sont l'occasion semble
tout de suite bah tu sais quoi on va
l'appeler tu veux appeler le docteur
sylvain on est très bien je vous attends
sont seulement ça marche
docteur simoni oui pardon de vous
déranger mais on a un petit souci
allô oui bonjour chloé et oscar interne
en quatrième année
dites moi docteur simoni comme je suis
censé gérer vos patients qui se pointe à
18 heures comme des fleurs en pleine
pénurie pour une fonction des sites pour
l'attendait d'où ce moment là je
comprends rien vous parlez de robert
s'est vite une ponction d'acide
oui a pas vraiment pourtant pas bien
compliqué comme gestionnaire de bon je
le suis depuis longtemps robert faut
s'en occuper
tant qu'il est là 1 s'il vous plaît je
compte sur vous ok merci
ont sans cesse donc
faut sortir le chien par contre oui oui
il beau tu fais rien bajeux si si si
j'étais en train de se faire une
ponction d'acitons est d'accord ouais
bah oui carrément
voilà super les bâtiments 116 avec
alison bales prévoir une aiguille de 14
ouais ce fait ouais
ce kit se référant à 3 janvier pourquoi
il faudrait qu'on a à faire et non nous
on piétine ça va aller le plan de
fonctions il ya un tiers 2/3
on tire au belize petit répit lilhac
ouais bah ouais c'est rien c'est bon ça
parlera pas aller pigna cloud qui sont
un peu plus bavard ouais ouais ça marche
il est allé un peu plus c'est pour ça
tout inquiète suite aux tirs voilà là
bien monsieur de robert héros mieux tout
à l'heure vous avez l'habitude de venir
on voit souvent ici souvent non ouais je
suis comme vous aimeriez pas d'obtenir
des solutions pour les gens un peu comme
vous qu'on est prêt avec l'alcool on
peut vous aider à arrêter si vous voulez
il ya go excuse moi le cg est arrivé
pour lattès
c'est ce dont tu peux j'y reste
désolé je m'appelle c'est un problème
vous inquiétez pas ça va très bien se
passer
je vais pitre
ça va
vous avez quel âge
pourquoi tu me donnes gainage
vous avez l'air jeune je pensais que les
études de médecine sa durée super
longtemps
justement j'ai pas fini est en train
d'étudier là
[Musique]
il est parfait soccer regarde le tracé
il est pas magnifique ce tracé était
montagne pile au bon endroit
[Musique]
mais par cet encart
alors comment ça se passe très bien
[Musique]
je me sens pas bien
t'as pas besoin
[Musique]
38 9 t'as pas vu c'est un nom plus grand
c'est quoi une infection japonais rien à
ses petits non c'était déjà infecté stop
la fonction arrête avec ton truc
le chaudron vert on allait faire
quelques prélèvements on va vous mettre
sensible aux accords et hanches mais il
faut nous dire la prochaine fois quand
ça va pas vous devez vous sentir pas
bien du tout là jeudi 7 octobre
[Musique]
où
clos elle est relou mais elle a surtout
inquiète
bon bah allez c'est ma tournée tu es ce
que tu bois tu aimes pas très bon choix
aussi prendre des mots names elle
transforme chaque lot tu crois kavanaugh
balancé à la gueule saint-pascal vitesse
ses silences et elle aimerait moi je
prends mon sandwich à rien tu vas
l'étrier la tiens moi je mange que les
rouges je te laisse tous les jours je
connais rouge bon je crois un
d'antibiogramme mais je pense que ça va
aller maintenant la fièvre est déjà un
pour tomber désolé pour la celle ci
s'est pas en dehors de celle ci je t'ai
dit arrête avec ça le problème c'est que
tu avais des jeux sur tes cours et pas
sur ton passion ça va tu seras la
prochaine fois
ça serait super ça vous pourrez parfait
merci d'avancé à bien mon copain public
vous salue bon je vais faire le premier
tour de garde comme ça je vous laisse
vous reposer mais je foutais et l'ajout
de gardes tu veux comme tu as beaucoup
plus travaillé que moi je sais tu es
fatigué tu peux te poser mais c'est
gentil je suis peu fatigué gerdemann ger
ensemble je virais le patient hugo
d'hectares les résultats de robert tu me
réveillant en ce cas c'est tout moi
c'est pas un ordre c'est un conseil
ouais tu peux jouer encore un peu plus
tard on a pris un petit sandwich
merci n'oublie pas ton téléphone de
service ah oui
cette étude tu peux pas laisser passer
moi j'ai jamais vu ça taxer les malades
c'est des grands grands maladie longue
carrière dans la folie qui les attend
c'est sûr il ya plus de sept truc qui
avait quand j'étais petit et tu parlais
que les petites secondes et comme à
charge par les proches quelque chose pas
la peine d'essayer parce que façon et
écoute pas parce qu'ils ne comprennent
pas ils ont des noms des langages
car elle est avec moi comme du verlan
mais c'est même pas d'urgence et
d'autres peuvent pas rester de nom sans
parler donc je me suis dit ok je vais
mettre au milieu on est en train de
travailler le basket donc tu vois les
tarifs mois la base
donc je commence doucement je leur
montre des trucs j'avais fait des petits
groupes autour je fais cela
et bleu
avaaz quoi on chez aurel agen
je vois qu'il n'a de 3,2
concentré
[Musique]
da krew je me rêve je regarde ça rigole
tout semble
ils sont fous mais j'ai pas une couche
je jure c'est dur d'être coincé là rien
[ __ ] ans tu sais ce que je fais je
trie mes mails mais j'essaie de me fais
a dit essayer
je reste un comme toi une
[Musique]
m
monsieur qu'est ce que vous faites là je
rentrais chez moi maintenant
non non non il fallait dormir la guitare
au bon bah oui et après on rentre rang
en 3 comme on appelait ça va pas ouais
enfin bon ça va tu es sûr
j'arrive pas à dormir j'aime bien voir
mon téléphone téléphone mais il est un
peu tard pour appeler quelqu'un là non
c'est pas pour téléphone ici pour jouer
candy crash c'est que ça va mieux leurs
intérêts
ok
[Musique]
sur la pole devant
mais marrante à coke
tiens vous êtes trop cool merci dont je
te laisses tu m'appelles si tu as besoin
chez dans le coin c'est de dormir un peu
quand même
[Musique]
tout va bien
ouais ça va toujours rien [ __ ] mais
qu'est-ce qui branlent la boum venant
ils ont envoyé les résultats moi c'est
bien une infection à une bactérie gram
positif c'est pour ça je te parie tiens
tu préfères le masque à oxygène
branche d'inspiration
hémoglobine à 6 c'est bon signe toi
monsieur robert je vais faire des
examens complémentaires d'accord je vous
met un tuyau dans la vie d'animal ses
commandes 3 kilos de plus et tu es bip
allison et on leur fait quand même un
groupe et des acp rail
ok le seul robert
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est drogba le
seul robert vous restez avec nous mais
je dois bien vous m'entendez la paire
face au tgv le temps et l'espace
en plus de l'infection il fait une
hémorragie interne ok alors je peux
trouver les formulaires assez bon chemin
n'occupe pas tant sur sa guise pas
besoin d'autre chose
la foire ans et 102 statines et c'est ça
marchera tu restes avec eux ok c'est
quoi ça c'est son chien il est troisième
à l'office
bon on stabilise en attendant les culots
c'est casse d'une voiture délais varient
sauf à vienne j'ai vu sa photo ex terme
on va lui passer 507 polyphonique et tu
prépares de quoi lui faire un lavage
place est ok allison sur est avec moi
pour moi qu'est-ce que je peux faire
alors on prend le relais
c'est un pansement il suggère
je vais piquer monsieur copé tient si tu
veux être utile aux capteurs du chat
occupe tête du chien tu ta duché
kaunas
bah non
alors maintenant tu m'entends s'est
refermée main si tu m'entends
[Musique]
oui oui médecine interne ou sur 250
pièces sept ans
[Musique]
sais pas c'est quoi
musicalement
ça devait être dans ses affaires
allez allez allez
turp et refuse tu me passes des gants de
woodstock
[Musique]
e
ben non c'est pas une urgence lente
c'est plutôt une urgence urgente à ses
clients tosca médecine interne
ça fait trois fois qu'on vous appelle
culot sont de statut la forme qu'on a
fait merci on compte une baudruche
percer là bas on a besoin d'être bon
passez-moi wagner bomba larouche y
attendait la tsk lts la ts est revenu à
ouais c'est ça super merci on joue au
boomerang avec la ps1 coups sûrs et un
point ici retour à l'envoyeur la vieille
alcoolo tout le monde sent bon travail
du sénat
[Musique]
éliminés
où
vous
oui maman je suis désolé que rien en ce
6 mai nature des varices autophagie et
je suis passé andrea et les trois
équipes sont prises les urgences c'est
pareil si tu veux pas revenir c'est bien
une rupture diverses se fait jean je
crois je crois un outil sûr surnom je
suis sûr si c'est pour voir avec la
chirurgie tu appelles de mazères du dès
que ces maquettes en bois
ok ok merci
docteur des majors
c'est le professeur albert qui
m'envoient c'est pour une rupture de
varices sauvagine ses ennemis ses nuits
je le peux pas j'ai trois blocs
programmée
[Musique]
e
bon
bonsoir
or ben basât oui pas encore dans les
patients non matin il est il est pas que
les schistes ar bed bath on appâte
l'information de gastro il a déjà fait
des offres de skopies jeu datant de la
scheer on devrait le laisser opérer
quand tu veux laisser opérer un légiste
non mais t'es sérieux
j'ai déjà fait des endoscopies en
albanie ça valait monsieur de robert
aucun mais il nous faut un endoscope
très bien je vais
alors homme de 61 ans sir au stade iv
rupture des varices aux fashion et avant
infections de l'équipe d'acide
[Musique]
ça
louis et le docteur sylvie veux te
parler
ouais bah ça fait deux ans qu'on se bat
pour le stabiliser
donc là on n'a plus le choix a t'on
chloé ça fait combien de temps qu'il n'a
pas touché un vivant ton légiste ben
justement si on attend encore il faudra
l'autopsié tondreau d'armé mais attends
c'est juste pas possible je veux pas te
laisser faire ça tu attends un blog tu
le maintien je suis désolé mais t'es pas
là allez maison fermât vont mettre sur
le côté il faut des compresses de l'eau
des seringues tient pas vous mettre en
jambes hathaway allait ouvrir la bouche
voilà dans sa manche pas savoir le ipad
58 verges en six ans elles ont eu le
temps de changer les machines se trouve
comment la mettre en route c'est gentil
ça marche pas totalement
ben alors il ya une colonne derrière la
colonne d'alimentation ya peut-être un
petit peu trop sur ça valait monsieur
probert a les jambes les patients dans
la bouche mais ça va pas durer longtemps
allez on s'en fout un kit d'élastiques
je sais pas c'est ça ouais
allez on y va allez messieurs robert on
va rentrer le tuyau mais vous inquiétez
pas j'ai pas grave mais ça va aller
si vous voulez
voilà c'est fait
[Musique]
ouais c'est bien une rupture de voirie
sur vingeanne
pour la voirie cela il faut que je
glisse l'élastique au taureau caire
monsieur et s'est pas bougé pour vous
calmer monsieur je la relis
il fait la première
[Musique]
attendez vous combien de temps encore le
temps qu'il faut à l'image de robert
travaillent et y en a pas pour longtemps
c'est un courant s'accroche
je drague la deuxième c'est tout a fini
non fort à ses joueurs rien
[Musique]
quoique c'est bon merci
c'est la dernière
c'est bon
ça valait monsieur robert gibbs
c'est bien monsieur robert kevin et je
mets
fais gaffe égard peut leur dire s'il
claque dont on va faire le tour c'est
rien merci à tous
ça va pour une première nuit d' interne
bien vivement que les médecins
reviennent c'est marrant je te voyais
pas fumer j'ai arrêté douze fois stade
est debout
non ça va ça
je fais pas ta non
vachement doucement
salut
en ce moment merci à toi bonsoir merci
[Musique]
on
oui
[Musique]
oh
je comprends bien et bâle est non non
mais vous me laissait voir avec eux et
puis je vous rappelle qu'au moment où
oui bien sûr évidemment très bien vous
ont fait ça merci on s'était cochin
passer par un méningocoque agents
pathogènes non identifiées donc la mise
à l'écart des médecins est prolongée
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
[Musique]
détachement maintenu un talon
e
[Musique]
à
chut